police are searching for a gunman after
a rush hour shooting in america's
biggest city the attack happened in a
subway station in brooklyn new york at
least 10 people were shot
but 16 in all have been injured
we didn't actually go downstairs which
we're glad we didn't but you know we saw
a ambulance coming out with a stretcher
with a person on it their leg was
injured i'm not sure exactly what went
on or what was going on and then we saw
after that two ambulance coming out with
two people like hopping on one leg
obviously they got her in the leg as
well so i'm not quite sure what's going
on or what's going on
well new york police are telling people
to stay away from where it happened it's
a 36th street station in brooklyn the
area is home to the busy chinatown and
is popular for its views of the statue
of liberty it's a large warehouse
district where many creative businesses
have set up
just before 8 24 this morning as a
manhattan-bound n train waited to enter
the 36th street station an individual on
that train donned what appeared to be a
gas mask
he then took a canister out of his bag
and opened it
the train at that time began to fill
with smoke
he then opened fire striking multiple
people on the subway and in the platform
again
we will describe him as an individual he
is being reported as a male black
approximately five feet five inches tall
with a heavy build
he was wearing a green construction type
vest and a hooded sweatshirt the color
is gray
the people of the entire state of new
york
stand with the people of the city this
community and we say no more
no more mass shootings
no more disrupting lives
don't worry creating heartbreak for
people just trying to live their lives
as normal new yorkers
it has to end it ends now
and we are sick and tired of reading
headlines about crime whether they're
mass shootings or the loss of a teenage
girl
or a 13 year old
it has to stop
the u.s president has been briefed about
the shooting other politicians have been
responding to the incident senate
majority leader chuck schumer tweeted
saying he's closely monitoring the
situation he says i'm praying for all
the victims their families all those
impacted i'm grateful for the quick
action of our first responders to
everyone in new york stay safe
let's speak to gabriel alexander who's
live for us in brooklyn new york
gabriel just bring us up to speed with
what we know now the latest with the
investigation
well there are still hundreds of law
enforcement officers here at the scene
we're just about a half block away from
one of the subway entrances it's right
there behind me it's still taped off
with police tape no one can obviously go
inside as
investigators are still combing through
that subway station looking for any
shell casings or any sort of evidence
that could be used in the future
but primarily
really just combing through that area as
this investigation continues this is
very much an active crime scene here but
it's not only here there's also hundreds
of police officers fanned out around
this area searching for this suspect
that's really priority one secondarily
the crime scene but even beyond that the
more urgent uh effort right now by law
enforcement is to try to find this
suspect urgently and until that can
happen uh they will be having a lot of
police fanned out through the area over
the coming
hours until they can arrest the suspect
gabriel what do we know about the
suspect
yeah all police are saying is that he's
a black male that uh he was wearing a
sort of a vest when he was on that
subway train at about 8 45 this morning
a packed train filled with commuters
going in to new york city some
students young kids as well because
there's a couple schools just within a
block of this subway station as well
when this suspect who apparently was
wearing some sort of gas mask released
some sort of uh smoke bomb of some kind
on that train and then opened fire
beyond that uh police are saying they do
not know his motive obviously at this
point and they also uh don't have any
they also don't know in which direction
he really fled at one time police were
actually
underground going walking through the
subway tracks the underground tracks
looking for the suspect they're still
doing a little bit of that but mostly
trying to figure out which way did he
run and where could that suspect
possibly be obviously a motive is going
to be key but i think as of now the
police say they simply have no motive
here
at this location in brooklyn you can
still see there's lots of police
officers here many of the streets are
still blocked off a little bit of calm
has been restored here
now that officers police and
investigators have said there's no
explosive devices in the subway station
at all is what someone was first was
reporting uh now the scene has really
shifted to various parts of the city as
they look for the suspect
all right thank you for that gabriel
alexander live for us from brooklyn new
york